are you ready jake to get your acting
face on and
i'm going to pretend pretend to be
surprised by all the content and it's
totally not the third time we've tried
requesting
knowledge i
[Music]
so assembly script um we've actually
talked about
it before like we mentioned it and kind
of introduced a little bit
um that was in our episode about
loops loop tiling yeah i think that's
where we're talking tiling and rotating
yes
this is an assembly a web assembly topic
is a semi script is a language for
webassembly
and we've talked about web assembly in
general
as well before but i think most of the
times i i showed web assembly a bit like
this
which is the web assembly human readable
text format
and i think you point out that many
humans might not enjoy
reading this at all even though it's you
know
letters the common file extension for
this file format
is what and it's very appropriate
i i mean to be fair as far as assembly
languages go
it is a good one i actually i think it's
more readable
that's like saying as far as the kray
twins go
ronnie is the best right you know that's
a loafer
sure but you know it's there it's it can
be up but i agree like this is not how
you want to write code it's not how you
want to read code
this is not usually where you're going
to put everything in production like
this and i think
the folks behind assembly script kinda
agreed because the alt and the
alternatives currently order to use
c and c plus plus or rust which are i
mean there's more
languages now compiling to webassembly
but i would argue c
and rust are the most predominant ones
the most well-known ones
um and i think part of that is that you
know as a web developer
we live our lives we live and breathe
javascript and typescript
and none of these languages just like c
and rust are
necessarily in our daily work i mean
maybe you know them but if you don't in
your web developer and you only use
javascript and css and html web assembly
seems a bit inaccessible and that's
exactly i think
what the assembly script folks wanted to
change because it's a language
designed for web assembly so in contrast
to like c and rust which were languages
that already existed
and that then added support for web
assembly
assembly script was designed for web
assembly specifically it is
you know it is still fairly low level
that's why they called assembly script
and as you can see here on the landing
page of the website they're
saying they're using the familiar
typescript syntax which is really nice
because
i think most of us are familiar with the
typescript syntax because it is pretty
much the javascript syntax with a couple
of editions here and there yeah and i
would say even if you're watching this
and you're not familiar with typescript
yeah
the important bit there is it's
additions to javascript so
like you'll look at typescript and
understand most of it and you'll be able
to see like there's just a couple of
extra bits
yeah exactly yeah and although one thing
we should be clear about and they are
very clear about this on the repository
it is definitely not a typescript to
webassembly compiler
it just reuses the syntax and the
language and
as far as they can the semantics the
code that you know
you read in assembly script looks like
typescript you think you know what it
does
it is very very likely that that's also
what it actually does once you compile
it
but it is not the case you can take just
existing typescript
throw in the assembly script and get
working web assembly out the other side
and when you say that it sounds like
you're going to have this huge uncanny
valley problem
because it's oh it looks like typescript
but it's not typescript it's not going
to work like you expect typescript to
work it's going to work like something
else
but in practice it's fine it actually
works really well
i think yeah and i think that's the
thing they try to mimic the semantics
of typescript as far as they can so that
you know if it looks like typescript it
will behave like typescript as far as
you know webassembly allows it's just
typescript in general
has things just don't work in website
like the same variable cannot hold
a string a number an object a class you
don't know until runtime
those things don't work in webassembly
and so they had to add some restrictions
to the language and also a different
type system
and that's kind of what i wanted to to
talk about a little bit but before
i think it's kind of important to talk
about why would you even use webassembly
and i think there's four major reasons
why you would be looking
into webassembly and the main reason we
have seen so far
in the webassembly ecosystem is making
use of existing code
so we have mscripten the compiler for
that brings c and c to plus web assembly
rust supports web assembly and so that
allows you to
make use of the entire ecosystem of
these two languages
and bring them to the web even though
those libraries might not have been
written with a web in mind
and that's really cool because not
everything is available
in a web compatible language and i think
that's something that we kind of
exploited almost with scrooge because
yeah there might be you know a jpeg
encoder
written in javascript there might be a
png encoder in javascript but i don't
think anyone has written down i sat down
yet
and wrote a avif encoder in javascript
or a jpeg xl encoder
um so we were at a loss until either the
browser shipped those
or we sat down and wrote them but
instead with webassembly
we can make use of these libraries
written in c and c plus and just
bring them to the web and that's really
cool however as i just said with
assembly script
that's kind of the case because you know
there's now some assembly script
specific libraries out
there but it wasn't targeting an
existing language so the whole
you know bring legacy code to the web
thing wasn't really
in arguments for assembly script to
begin with
but it is one of the major use cases
that we see for people to look into
webassembly
the next point which you know many
people bring up is performance and
even though like i've been very very
vocal about the fact that webassembly
and javascript
for the longest time had the same peak
performance they were optimized by the
same engine they both
generated you know machine code under
the hood and so really
they have the same peak performance they
could reach
the difference is that for javascript to
get optimized it needs to run
it needs to be observed because just
from the code you cannot tell
what kind of type a variable has which
you need to generate machine code
while with webassembly that is already
encoded in the webassembly file
so the engine for javascript needs to
run the javascript observe it and then
start
optimizing as it runs the code and many
javascript optimization experts have
you know have experienced this this
warm-up phase as they often call it when
your code runs slower at the start
and then gets faster which is often also
seen in benchmark that run a couple of
loops which they don't measure
because warm up in webassembly the
optimizing compiler kicks in
immediately and so we have a fast
compiler which is called
liftoff which generates code really
really fast at the cost of not
generating optimal code and then the
website can start running
as fast as possible but the second that
compiler is done the optimizing compiler
called turbofan kicks in
and starts optimizing one function at a
time and switches them out bit by bit
um even if you haven't even run your web
assembly so just with a bit of waiting
you will just get optimized webassembly
code under the hood
yeah i think it was uh ashley williams
who said the difference between
javascript and webassembly is that the
performance is reliable with webassembly
as in you're in control of when things
like garbage collection happen that sort
of thing and
yeah a lot of the optimizations happen
up front so
it's easier to measure the performance
of webassembly code
and it's not going to change in between
runs exactly i think that's really well
put it here it makes just
ha webassembly is just much more
predictable in how it will behave
because in javascript you also have the
phenomenon that you know you can call
the same function with a string and with
an object and with an array
as i said like the engine observes if
this function
gets called with a string all the time
then it generates machine code
for handling a string but the first time
you call it with a different type
it then has to fall back to interpreting
because the machine code is wrong now if
you call it with an array all of a
sudden
and that is called a d optimization a d
opt which will slow you back down and so
while you can reach peak performance
with javascript it can also be
kind of fall back to becoming slower
with webassembly that's not possible
because
everything is strongly typed the third
point and there's actually something
that you already
kind of mentioned it now which is
there's more performance
on the one hand webassembly is getting
increasing
access to things that javascript doesn't
have access to
like actual shared memory concurrency
with threads
simdee which there was proposals back in
the day for javascript but they have
banned them all in favor of webassembly
and what you just said because you are
or the language
decides what part of the runtime to ship
things
like garbage control can be under your
control
so in javascript there is a garbage
collector and it will run
and sometimes you don't want it to run
but there's not much you can do about
that except
you know bend your code backwards to
prevent garbage collection the first
space by keeping references around
but in webassembly you can actually
change the garbage collector for
something that works more in how you
like it and that is like
something i think game engines for
example would really really like because
they often like to decide
when there is a good time for garbage
collection and when it is not a good
time
for garbage collection and lastly and
this is going to be interesting is
binary size because the spec says that
one of the design goals is that the
webassembly
binary format the the virtual the
bytecode file
is a very small binary representation of
the code that it contains
but then i mean the codecs we have in
squoosh are not small
but yeah is that is that just because
they're big code or is that down to
more of the like the standard library
sort of stuff that
c and rust need it's it's all of the
above really
on the one hand an image encoder will
have a lot of logic
and i think if you wrote in javascript
it would also be quite big
but at the same time it is what you said
that you know webassembly is a pure
abstract vm and in javascript we already
have
you know people often say javascript
doesn't have a standard library but the
web platform does provide
a huge amount of code that's just in the
browser and you can handle strings you
can handle arrays you can iterate over
them you can map them you can filter
them
you can split strings join strings
filter strings all these things are just
there if you
do use that logic in webassembly or in a
language compiling to webassembly
that code needs to get compiled and put
into the binary as well
and then lastly there's also the aspect
that webassembly has a strictly
numerical interface to javascript so
whenever you want to
pass anything that is not a number an
object an array a string
from javascript to webassembly and back
there needs to be a bit of javascript
which is called the glue code often
that converts between what the
webassembly file understands and what
javascript understands
that is also code that we actually ship
over and over in scrooge
um so we have actually not made great
experiences with binary size although i
will say a that webassembly compresses
really really well with broadly in gzip
and it is very compressible often you
know eighty percent of the filter just
goes away and you're left with twenty
percent of the original size
um but also that you can make these
modules
very very small at times but with tools
like m script and russ it is quite hard
to remove
like it just assumes that you need a lot
of standard library even if you don't
and
it sometimes takes a lot of work to get
rid of all these bits that you could
sometimes do in a different way
and but we've seen and i think we talked
about this in our loop tiling episode
where we made the web assembly actually
be smaller than the
comparable javascript code yes yes we
did
all right i think that was enough
waffling it is time for some kodi bits
at least something that is close to code
which is
install command it's closer it will it
will lead us to the code jake
you you don't worry uh you have seen the
slide deck before three times you know
you don't have to worry
so with this command you install
assembly and it's actually kind of nice
that it's just on npm
um it uses the web assembly itself under
the hood which i thought it's kind of
interesting but you don't really notice
when you use it if this is too much of a
commitment for any of our viewers
you can also just go to
webassembly.studio where you can
try out m scripting with c and z plus
rust and assembly script in a little you
know ide in the browser that compiles in
the browser you can just play around
without having to install anything so
both of these uh
paths are completely valid to play
around with webassembly a little bit
all right time for our first assembly
script
code this is a typescript file in this
case it's in a semiscript file it
exports a function called main
and returns 42 anyone who knows
typescript should be fairly comfortable
with reading this we can compile it
so the assembly script compiler is
called ase because it's the assembly
script compiler very intuitive
and we passed our main.ts file and with
dash b
we say the binary output file should be
main.wasm
and now the only thing left to do is
really load this file somehow
in the browser you know probably with an
html page and
that would look like this we just use
webassembly.instantiatestreaming and
throw the fetch in there of the wesm
file it will give us back an
instance and every exported function
will be on
instance.export so you really get a
webassembly
module instance and that module has
exports just like the modules we have
been writing in that assembly file and
so there's like a really nice clear
mapping between webassembly modules
and code modules if you want to talk
about them that way
and this would pretty much exactly lock
the number 42
into your console success if you're into
it the compiler can also generate this
human readable text format i showed at
the start
that can be helpful sometimes to see if
certain exports are present or suddenly
have a different name
or maybe even you want to see what the
function looks like
it can sound this beautiful but it's
definitely not required to use this
at all what is important is that the
assembly script compiler by default
uses no optimizations to make it a fast
but also to make source maps work really
clearly there's a very clear mapping
from
webassembly code blocks to individual
commands in the
assembly script file which means you can
step through your assembly script code
in devtools which is really really nice
for a debugging experience
even though one thing i should note
something that doesn't work is like
inspecting variables like you can't
hover over a variable
um to see its current value because
source maps cannot contain that kind of
mapping but there is something in the
works there as far as i know
but if you end up shipping your assembly
script
webassembly to production make sure you
use the dash o flag which is
you know an optimization path which will
not only make your assembly script code
even faster
but probably also significantly smaller
so this is quite important but
this is pretty much it this is how you
use a semiscript
and as you already pointed out the
return type is a bit weird because if
you know typescript
you also know that this is not a
typescript type
um and i think this is so vs code if you
use it will probably put a nice
red squiggly line under it but this is
one of the differences between
assembly script and typescript in that
they changed the types
from you know javascript has numbers and
string while
webassembly only has unsigned 32-bit
integers which is what this is it has a
couple more i won't get into that
but you know these types are a direct
mapping from what webassembly supports
to the language that you're writing
which is actually
quite nice so this is where it's
different to typescript because
in typescript the types are used as like
validation as part of the compilation
step
but in assembly script here like these
are runtime types
exactly well they're both they're also
validation at compile time but yeah
that's exactly right that these carry
over
to the runtime and actually impact what
kind of code
is being generated as i said you
assemble vs code by default will
probably put a red quickly line under it
to fix that they do provide a default
tsconfig.json that you can just
extend and then it will actually the red
squiggly lines will go away and vs code
will
nice i think this is kind of valid
typescript so things like refactoring
jump to definition all those things will
work
and that's actually really really neat
all right let's make our assembly script
code a bit more interesting
we are now going to use an import we're
going to import a function from a
different module
you can split up your code into multiple
modules and import and export stuff like
you're
used to from javascript and typescript
and the compiler will take care of like
bundling it all together and you know
linking and
recognizing which function you're
actually calling so that shouldn't be
very surprising
so in this case i also create a utils.ts
file and now we want to look at the
implementation of alert obviously
but there is none and this is really
interesting because the declare
keyword also exists in typescript and it
tells the typescript
validator basically that i assure you
this function exists once you run this
code i just haven't implemented it
myself
yeah so it's common to use this like if
there's a an api that
the browser supports but typescript
doesn't know about it yet
this is you use declare for that to say
look it's here it looks like this
exactly and so you were saying you know
we're declaring this function exists and
that this module will export it which
kind of doesn't make sense but you know
we're kind of saying this is what
reality will look like in the end
and so what this means that now the
assembly script compiler will say all
right
i'm just going to you know note down
this function takes a u32
and i will be provided a function for
this later
and so if we now used our instantiate
streaming call this would actually throw
because it says hey the utils module
expected an alert function but you
didn't give me one i can't run this
and so what you need to do is you
actually need to provide a so-called
imports object for the instantiate
function and it looks like this we're
saying okay it's an
object of modules and we can just
provide functions what you see here i'm
literally just passing through
window.alert which we all know and love
our good old debugging days so this way
it is really cool that we can not only
call from javascript into webassembly
our main function
but our main function can now call back
into javascript
through this imports object that's
amazing so like
so here we're passing a javascript
function into assembly script which we
can call
but presumably you could even you could
compile some webassembly from
c plus or rust and take its exports and
make them
imports into assembly scripts so you're
using assembly script to call rust which
is calling c
plus which is called javascript and it
that just all works that that's exactly
you could do that and that's actually
kind of fascinating and think is
something that even we and scooch don't
do yet and we could look into that
but yeah you can base just anything that
is available in the
host environment which in the browser is
javascript you can just use that as an
import and then that will just kind of
work as long as you stick to the types
that webassembly understands or that
webassembly knows how to convert
convert to javascript and vice versa
let's make it a bit more interesting
jake i've asked you this quiz before but
i will ask it to you again
what do you think is different about
this example than all our other ones
i don't think array.push will work
because
this is not typescript it's not
javascript this is
assemblyscript so like arrays work
but maybe not like array methods work
things like your the prototype chain
that sort of stuff's
not going to be there right and no that
is not right
uh because that this is actually what
people mean when they say a language is
shipping its own runtime
assembly script actually has an
implementation for these
growable arrays um so all these methods
do exist and they will cause code to be
added to your webassembly binary and
this is what i mean like it starts to
ship more and more runtime
the more you start using it but this
works they actually have
memory management and i think this for
me is the big difference in this we are
now
in memory management territory because
we can push into arrays as much as we
want which means our memory usage can
grow
which also means at some point we can
run out of memory and so the second you
use this kind of code
your instantiate streaming will start to
fail again because it will say hey
i'm expecting you to provide me in a
board function because
something we need something that gets
called when things go wrong or assembly
script needs something that it can call
when things go wrong
and so it expects for this u32
array to have an abort method in case
the push doesn't succeed because it
might
you know try to grow the the memory and
if that's not available
and the board function actually takes
parameters so you can figure out
which actual function from which actual
file caused
this abort so the way i'm handling the
error here is probably not very elegant
um but i wanted to explain why this is
suddenly there
overall i would actually recommend to
make use of the assembly script loader
which takes care of
all of this for you not only does it
provide an abort function but it also
generates the appropriate error messages
to tell you in this file this function
call on this line
costs the abort and here is the actual
error description fix your code
right uh so the exchange loader takes
care of
all these little details under the hood
for you gives you a proper board
function that
you know gives you in this file on this
line something went wrong here's the
error message
fix your code so most of the time i
would recommend using the same script
loader because it is actually not that
big
and just takes care of the basic
fundamentals of like good error messages
for you right what's what's not that big
like that
like um well what are we talking about
because the the glue code for
inscription and rust can
can be quite big so right
so the good news about this code is that
the loader is not
module specific with m script you get
glue code generated for each webassembly
file
and so even though they share some code
you will your user will end up double
loading it
the same scripts loader you only need
once for
doesn't matter how many assembly script
modules you have and i think
even then if you use everything it
provides i think we're talking about
1k gzipped so it's definitely not
something that
should hurt you that much to load into
your bundle which i think is really
really nice
all right let's make it a bit more
interesting because as i said the
interface
webassembly supports is pretty strictly
numerical
but as developers we know that we work
with more than just
numbers most notably strings are usually
a primitive that we often use
and so you know i turned our main
function now into a function that takes
a name as a string
and our alert function now also takes
the string which you know in javascript
land is true and so far the conversion
just happened to work
but now we want to pass an actual string
value one thing that we will need to do
is now to export the runtime because
strings are
run time values they are not you know
something that can just be passed along
as a parameter but that needs to be a
pointer to a string and so by
exporting the runtime we can create
those strings
through the api that the module exposes
and this is something again that the
same script loader can take
care of for you so it exposes two
functions
among many others a new string function
that creates a new string
in a semi script land that a semi script
can then understand and a getstring
function that
turns a number a message pointer back
into a string in javascript land
this is not very nice i it i think i
kind of like the approach that they give
you a non-automatic interface so that
you are in control
when the conversion happens and you
exactly know
you know no cost here is hidden from you
you can see that there's
extra function calls happening to make
this interface work
but i i definitely feel that you know
you have to know your interface very
well and it is a lot of extra work it
makes it
very noisy we can't just pass through a
lot anymore we have to write
a wrapper alert function there is
something that does it better which is
called asbind which is a library from
one of the
core maintainers of assembly script that
tries to do all of this
automatically for you and that can be
really really nice so if you want to use
that
i would recommend looking at a readme
and even this library i actually don't
know how big it is but it
is still way below the glue code that we
usually see
in some of the the more established
languages
all right one last thing i want to talk
about which i mentioned earlier is
the run time itself by default the
runtime that is used is called
incremental so i have it explicitly as a
flag here but
you don't need to specify because that's
the default that is a full automatic
garbage collector that every now then
will just run and collect all the memory
and freed up of things you don't
use anymore that will add about
three to four kilobytes of gzipped web
assembly to your webassembly file
depending on how many runtime functions
you use and that's not too bad either i
mean like
we start to get concerned about that
kind of file size when it's
blocking your initial render or you're
blocking fetching some data or something
like that but
we tend to use webassembly in a way
that's it's lazy loaded right it's you
you get an initial render down and then
the web assembly comes to do something
else
so in terms of that a few k is nothing
exactly i think it's an absolutely
acceptable payload but it is a garbage
collector that will just run every now
and then i think they just inject
garbage collect calls at the end of
functions or something i don't know but
as i said you know sometimes when you
have a really high performance use case
like a game that wants to ship 60 frames
a second
that might be unacceptable and for that
they provide a second runtime
which is called minimal it is still a
full garbage collector
with memory management and everything
but it doesn't garbage collect until you
explicitly call the function to tell it
to garbage collect
and that can be really nice so sometimes
it might be worth your while to you know
build up some unused memory that is
still allocated and then
once you know you know the level is over
you're showing your high score at the
ends
where the frame rate isn't as important
anymore or you know there's not much
input happening
that's where you run the garbage
collector and i think that's actually
really interesting
there even is a stop runtime
which we used in the past for our image
rotation
example because we actually just we
exactly knew what kind of memory we need
how much we need we didn't want to free
up any memory
and that basically reduces the 3k
almost completely from the file i think
it's about 500 600 bytes gzip that are
left
because you can still allocate memory
but you can't free it anymore
but this is completely adequate for
these modules that you instantiate you
run them and you throw them away which
is exactly what we did with the image
rotation we just
create a new instance put in the image
waited for it to rotate the image got it
back out and then the module gets
destroyed and if we want to rotate again
we create a new one and in that case you
could actually use
semi script even for render critical
code i probably wouldn't recommend that
because you still need to load it
instantiate it
but yeah you can you can really squash
the file size down you could even
this flag even accepts a file so if you
wanted to you could write your own
runtime but we're not going to get into
that because that obviously needs a bit
more
detailed knowledge about about
webassembly and memory management and
let's start easy but the the design here
is
brilliant right and it's something that
a lot of you know javascript projects
javascript libraries javascript
frameworks
could really learn from this uh layered
approach
because it's great to know that well
okay so we've given you the the easiest
thing but here's a flag you can swap it
out for something simple or you can even
write your own
like you can control the whole stack if
you want
i really like this design i i also think
it's
it's a very nice approach and it's very
extensible in general
and they have a discord linked on their
main website which is linked here which
is super helpful community
so if you are trying to get started but
you're getting stuck
there's always someone in that discord
channel willing to help
um but this was basically my assembly
script
speedrun introduction yes i would say
like
if you're unfamiliar with lower level
programming languages like like me uh so
i don't have
a lot of background in c or c plus plus
i found assembly scripts really easy to
get started with because it was in that
familiar
javascript-esque typescript esque
environment but it was just introducing
the more manual memory management stuff
and sort of lower level types
i find it really easy to get going with
and write some really optimized
uh webassembly code well there's no
better way
to end them with that if the light falls
over
it it will change the shot quite
dramatically
and it'll knock all kinds of over sorry
okay it'll be
funny if it falls over won't it breaks
your nose
blood everywhere humor